I have made it to Leviathan as you can
see this I've been hosting portraits
here for like six or seven years always
super special I don't know if it's gonna
happen this year because pandemic no but
I'm here it took like weeks of airports
and quarantine to get here but I think
it was worth it it's gonna be pretty
boring cuz you know nobody's here except
mark and I but yeah I'm hoping to make
some point nth if I get some inspiration
if you have any questions that really
helps me so we'll see what I come up
with I wanted to say thank you for a lot
of support I've received you know
through Facebook recently a lot of you
expressed a lot of friendship and loved
and that really means a lot to me it's
helping me and people have totally been
helping spreading word in the online
courses which is also good because
that's like my only revenue stream these
days and they make people happy people
really like the courses so it's total
win-win and I'm pitching my patreon
campaign again we'll see how that goes I
feel funny about that but yeah we'll see
I don't know what I'm gonna do this
summer and I bet you're where you are
not knowing what you're gonna do this
summer but if we all stay in contact who
knows Nick reporting from the Bison
studio where I'm sure something will
happen
[Music]